thank you so much Tina it is an absolute
privilege to be here I remember so
fondly sitting in these seats helping
organize this lecture series there's
actually quite a few people here that I
recognized from years ago when I when I
used to help lead this so it is amazing
to be here so I wanted to start out very
briefly on the Twitter side about a
month and a half ago I was asked to take
on our consumer products so the Twitter
product you're familiar with and leading
that effort and who here got a chance to
play with our moments launch that
happened last week if you heard of it
okay good yo Murph you you ok I would
highly recommend you give it a shot this
is a very cool way to see some of the
best content on Twitter and the reason
you should go check it out when you have
a moment is this is exactly what I'm not
going to talk about and so we're not
going to talk about twitter anymore what
I want to do is talk about startups and
I actually wanted to start by thanking
Tina and Tom literally they have been my
entire introduction to entrepreneurship
I learned everything that I know in this
room I was fortunate enough to hear
about etl the first week of my freshman
year and I went to that etl and I
literally went to every single one off
for years so i went to 96 straight and
it was fascinating and as i was thinking
about speaking here that's part of why
it's such an honor to be back it really
struck me that the most interesting ones
during my time here were the ones that
were very concrete very practical very
down-to-earth about early stage startups
and what we could do and as a student I
was super interested in that and so I
wanted to talk as concretely as possible
about startups and hopefully live up to
some of the great speakers we've had
over the years this is Carly Fiorina
obviously current presidential candidate
this was shortly after she left HP and
came and spoke to us and so here's
hoping I probably can't but we'll see if
I can live up to some of the great talks
of the past so thank you again for
having me all right so what I want to
talk about is lessons from acquisitions
and I've had some incredible
opportunities to see a whole bunch of
these from different sides and so I want
to talk through this in three chapters
the first is selling my startup in creo
to box in 2009 and then in 2013 selling
crashlytics to Twitter and then over the
past two and a half to three years at
Twitter I've had an incredible
opportunity to see thing
from the other side of the table and so
I've been involved in a number of deals
on Twitter side most notably periscope
and so I wanted to share some of the
lessons I've learned from that side
since I think it's it's a little bit
different and it's very different and a
little interesting for someone from the
startup perspective so let's dive in
let's talk about boxing and creo so
first off you're probably curious what
actually was in creo I'm sure almost
none of you have heard that name in creo
was a project i started with a couple of
friends here my senior year I was about
January and we became very very
interested in the concept of idea
sharing and collaboration how could we
build tools that would help people
whether they were freelancers or within
companies or students share their ideas
get feedback on their ideas and iterate
and improve the documents they were
trying to put out in support of those
ideas and so this was actually a first
mock it was the code name was feedback
ER because this was the era when flickr
had made it very cool to have an r after
whatever random word you wanted for your
startup and so we had feedback ER and
the concept was simple you upload your
file and you share it with a few people
and then they can go and give you
feedback on the file and we were
fortunate enough after a bunch of
discussions to be able to raise a seed
round of funding for that februari from
dfj and so we were sort of often running
as current seniors which was ridiculous
we were trying to still go to class and
make this happen and we ended up
launching in May a few weeks before
graduation on TechCrunch I like this
photo because if you remain OTT remember
TechCrunch at one point didn't have many
ads and was very clean and easy to see
and read home which was a lot of fun and
so we launched on TechCrunch and what
happened well we had a great spike and
then somewhat terrible to say but about
two weeks later traffic went back down
to effectively zero and so this is to
just share with everyone that you think
you're doing everything like oh my god
we built this product it works like
people are using it people sign up we
launched on TechCrunch oh we have to be
successful no not at all it turns out
that that is just the start of the
journey and so we didn't give up we
hadn't graduated yet and so we kept
working on it slowly built a team over
the course of that summer kept chugging
on both the product and the marketing we
begged bloggers all across the internet
to write about it finally started
getting some articles finally started
getting some traction
and we kept iterating the product of
course that year to something that was
relatively complex for the time it will
allowed you to sew a hundred different
file formats in your web browser whether
their powerpoints or PDF or native
photoshop or native illustrator files
and then you could give feedback all in
real time so everyone on that page could
see people drawing on the document and
adding comments and so on the problem
was on the growth side and so it turned
out that the product really appealed to
freelancers and freelancers loved it
because they needed a way to communicate
with their clients and get feedback on
the design they were doing and iterate
from there but it was a real struggle to
grow up past that market and so we wound
up getting a great audience a great
customer base of about 20,000
freelancers and it was a big challenge
to grow it past that and so a spring of
12 2009 came around we had to go back to
sand hill road we needed more funding in
order to keep the company operating and
for those of you who remember that
period 2009 was perhaps one of the worst
times to raise funding in the past
decade because the housing bubble had
just burst actually the previous October
of 2008 Sequoia had put out this
presentation that said r.i.p good times
and everyone sort of stopped investing
and pulled back and was afraid that the
end times were upon us and whatever was
going to happen and so here we were as a
tiny six-person startup with a small
product with 20,000 users trying to
raise funding and the challenge with
that is if you're going to go out for an
a round you need to present a really
compelling idea and a really big
opportunity in order to justify further
investment and this little freelancer
project was not going to cut it and so
here's an actual slide from our actual
pitch deck we decided hey this could be
the start of a new way of exploring file
formats what if you could actually take
any file and break it down into its
component pieces add metadata on it and
then render it anywhere on the web and
so you could allow different web
applications to edit or mutate different
parts of the file now I don't know what
you think about that idea but the VC is
pretty much were not impressed and we're
totally confused what we meant and we
ended up actually talking with 36 firms
around Silicon Valley over the course of
that spring and all of them gave us the
thumbs down and so where do we go from
there well this of course now you're
sort of in a in a more
in state we have about six months of
runway left in terms of cash we had in
the bank we need to go do something with
it and so the great thing is with
constraint comes tons of creativity how
can we go survive as a company and how
could we find some way some sort of
capital to get us keep going as a quick
sidebar I can't believe there's an emoji
that's money flying I don't know why
that is but there is uh-huh and so how
could we go do this well we started
really looking at what we had built and
we quickly realized that the probably
the most valuable thing of the company
wasn't necessarily our user base or the
product as a whole but was the
technology we built we had built this
back-end system to convert a hundred
file formats to flash because this was
2009 and that's what you did uh-huh and
so we had this conversion engine that we
thought could be really powerful there
were tons of different companies on the
internet that dealt with documents very
few of them if any of them could
actually display those files in the
browser and so we started thinking hey
this could be a path forward and so what
if we approached a bunch of those
companies and offered to partner with
them and maybe they pay us a penny per
document or whatever it could be and in
exchange we would power their document
conversion and we would give them our
document player is what we called it and
this would allow them to show files
within their site and so that's exactly
what we did we went around the valley
and pitched a bunch of companies on this
partnership and here are some actual
mocks we did for box where you have a
file in your box account and then you
click preview and you would see a
preview of it right there within a few
seconds and that could be pretty cool
and what really blew our mind here is
that we're all the VCS did not like our
sort of future looking vision this was a
very concrete thing this was a very
clear need that these companies had and
they could really rationalizes like this
is something what's doing to radically
improve our product experience and we
immediately had four companies that
wanted to go partner with us the
challenge was they had some interesting
constraints and they were pretty much
Universal with these constraints they
wanted it to be exclusive so that their
competitors the other ones on this list
didn't have the same technology and they
wanted to host it themselves because if
they were to send their private
documents their user documents out to
our systems they would have to change
their privacy policies they have to tell
their user base it would be a whole
legal mess and it would just be a lot of
extra infrastructure they would have to
build and so that all sounded reasonable
the challenge is okay from us is the
startup side let me get this straight
you want to host our technology and we
can't give it to anyone else because it
has to be exclusive that doesn't really
sound like a partnership to me that
sounds pretty aggressive that sounds a
little bit more like an acquisition and
so we actually said that point blank to
these four companies or like so what do
you what's do your path forward what do
you propose here well three of them gray
excluded moved forward and actually made
acquisition offers and this stunned us
we were not expecting this we're like
wow we were just trying to find a route
forward for the company find a way to
break even so that we could keep
developing our technology and now
actually we had all these interesting
offers on the table and so as we're
thinking through this how do we start
evaluating which path to take and so you
would do what anyone did and go through
and try to make some pros and cons and
so how do we think about these companies
well red was really compelling read had
absolutely massive scale and these were
the actual code names we used red had
actually massive scale and so that's
compelling we wanted to be able to power
this for a large number of people to
sort of stay true to our vision and help
people collaborate on documents and we
got the sense that they were actually
willing to pay quite a bit for this
technology they saw the need they really
understood how powerful this could be
for their product then of course there
were some cons it was not a great
culture fit this was a this was a older
company they had been around awhile they
had a very corporate culture and they
were down in San Jose and being recent
grads we weren't certain we wanted to
move down to San Jose they also were
requiring that we rewrite our whole
technology stacks so we had written in
Ruby it was a great language to iterate
on it very quickly prototype stuff get
it into production they were all
java-based they said oh if you come in
you you can't do Ruby you have to
rewrite this into Java and that was a
challenge because we felt this would
probably take 18 months or so to rewrite
there was a lot of technology we had
built their purple was about middle of
the road so there was a good culture fit
that's fine but we weren't super
passionate about their business they
were more focused on the wiki space and
we just didn't really understand where
that would go and pan out and how this
would become a huge thing blue had a
great culture fit and a really clear
product need so
had decent scale not quite as big as red
but they still had a lot of scale and it
could fit in the product really nicely
and we loved the team we've gotten to
know them actually over the course of
the prior year but it was clear that
they were not willing to pay a lot they
were a pretty small company at the time
and so that was something we would have
to deal with as we wait our options and
so as we thought about this we very
quickly ruled out purple it was sort of
middle of the road there wasn't anything
really bad or really great about it but
we were struggling a lot between red and
blue and so who thinks we went with red
man's Wow who things were going with
blue everyone that's exactly right
that's exactly right and so we made the
decision okay all things considered we
would far more value the culture and the
path going forward then we did the money
at the time we weren't in this to try to
make a lot of money we were in this to
build this tool and help people
collaborate and we felt if we could have
a very successful integration in
partnership with box that would be a
strong way forward and fortunately
that's exactly what we ended up doing so
here's a screenshot from box about nine
months later and our technology directly
powered all of their document preview
within the product for about five years
which was pretty cool and so I wanted to
sort of step back and talk about lessons
learned from this and so as you reflect
or do a retro on this moment so even
though this was our totally first time
through this process it was actually not
only our first experience being acquired
we were the first company box bought and
so lovey had never acquired anyone
before and also was trying to learn this
as he went through it and but we did
actually managed to get a few things
right in retrospect we did focus on the
future not on the moment and I think
this is deeply deeply important there
are so many founders I talked to today
who are looking to sell their company
and everything they seem to talk about
is the day the deal closes although
we're going to make this much money and
it's going to put my team in great shape
and oh we're going to have some great
press around it i'm going to look
brilliant and all this stuff and that
actually has almost nothing to do with
your success because when you go through
an acquisition you're going through with
the next three to four years of your
life working for that company and why
would you value this one day this one
moment in time more than the next four
years combined if your experience I've
actually build
out and realizing the vision of what
you're going to try to go do together
and so I am fortunate we did not go with
red if we did not stay focused on the
money and I think we got this exactly
right we also optimized for culture fit
the more I've learned the more critical
this has become to me is there are many
great companies in the valley but the
one that's right for you is the one that
do you deeply identify with on a
cultural level that you love the people
there you love what you're working on
and you have a blast working together
with them on it and so we had gotten to
know the Box team over the prior months
they were also funded by dfj and we had
a really strong sense that we liked the
people there and we thought we could do
great stuff together now we did get a
lot of things wrong and so I wanted to
talk through these we waited too long so
as I talked to we did this fundraising
process that did not pan out and then we
started thinking about partnership
opportunities and then ultimately
acquisition opportunities because of
this we had a very short runway to
pursue the acquisition and so we
couldn't fully evaluate every possible
option we basically approach the top
four firms that we thought would be
interesting on a partnership side but if
there had been much more time we could
have gone much deeper been far more
strategic about the partnership or
acquisition that we were pitching and
gotten to be a little bit in a stronger
negotiating point so that we could
perhaps have come out with a better
monetary outcome even though that wasn't
important we were all so overly
transparent and this I think is really
interesting because I am deeply for
transparency within companies and but I
think there's a caveat to that I think
as a founder of a startup it is your
responsibility to gauge how transparent
or not to be and your ultimate job is to
reduce stress for your team and so in
many circumstances actually being more
transparent reduces stress because
people see the picture they understand
where things are and they can go do
their job but in certain cases
particularly I found in acquisitions the
stress of going through that process is
immense and it is almost certainly your
job as a founder to try to reduce that
stress for your team and prevent them
from having to go through the same
process you are because we started
talking with box and these other firms
about three months before we ended up
and so even with a relatively small
relatively simple deal it still takes
quite a bit of time and during that time
our entire team of sex was visibly
stressed people didn't know what to work
on we didn't know whether to continue
our roadmap or to go and build what we
think box might have wanted or maybe we
do some experimentation and we build
some things that red wanted and some
things that blew on ads so we could see
the whole world it was just a lot of
confusion and ultimately lost
productivity because the net result of
that is we built almost nothing during
those three months because we were so
confused about which direction to take
and so in retrospect we should have
probably not told the team we were going
to this process and we should have
brought them in when we were more
certain of the direction so that we
could have kept executing towards our
original goal as a start-up before
making this transition we also again
because we hadn't been used to this
process we didn't know what to negotiate
and neither did Aaron Levie we didn't
get any commitment on boxes part 2
continued investment and so they were
excited by that technology we came in we
built it we integrated it into their
systems and then over time we
transitioned off and worked on different
projects across the company which was a
great experience and we learned a lot
doing that but what turned out to happen
is that box actually under invested in
document preview over the course of
those five years and a year and a half
ago head to buy Crocodoc in order to
make up for that and so Crocodoc was a
company that started right after we were
sold and was basically the next
generation of conversion technology and
so because box under invested in it we
didn't have the next iteration of the
technology and they had to go make
another acquisition in the space so
that's the first story all right let's
talk about crashlytics and for that we
have to talk about crash reports so
crashlytics comes from the fact that we
did transition off document preview and
conversion well at box and i started
leading boxes sync project which was
effectively their answer to dropbox and
if any of you have ever worked on sync
clients they it turns out they are
horrific they are incredibly complex to
build an incredibly buggy and maybe it
was just ours but it crashed constantly
and this was sort of the seed of the
idea in my mind for crashlytics so we I
put some simple
code into our sync client that if it
crashed detected that and uploaded a
report to our server and this is a
prototypical Apple crash report this is
one I actually pulled from the Twitter
app but it is incredibly cryptic and so
we shipped this build of our sink line
out to beta testers and a week later we
had six thousand reports sitting on our
server that's how many times it had
crashed and this was actually worse
because now we were frustrated that we
knew how bad it was but we didn't have
time to read through six thousand of
these and understand exactly what was
going wrong and it struck me that this
problem was actually automatable the
answer is in these numbers these hex
codes which are the memory addresses of
the call stack when it crashed and if
you could actually back out the line
number of code from that instruction
pointer you could determine exactly
where the crash occurred in the app and
so that's what I started working on as a
side project I built an SDK for iOS
initially and then we built an Android
one to basically detect that crash time
that the application was crashing gather
all the data it needed and then the next
time the user launched the app upload
that to our server and box was actually
fantastic through this process I had
told them hey I'm interested in building
this I don't want to do it for box
because I think would be broadly useful
but it's something I want to work on on
the side and to their complete credit
they said hey great go for it like work
on at nights and weekends and if it's
good maybe we'll use it one day and so
often running and started a project
called crashlytics and crafts oolitic
stood exactly this we were able to
mirror and pair the debugging data from
the device with the compiler data the
developer had when they were building
the app and from that we can actually
extract precise line numbers and method
names of the exact line that crashed and
then we can aggregate these into issues
so that you know exactly how many bugs
you have and how important they are so
you can fix the top ones first and so
this the trajectory was night and day
from an creo and creo we were struggling
to find these freelancers do a lot of
marketing and tried just begging people
to try out the product and use it and
this blue me blew my mind this was
completely different I started telling
friends about it they were desperate to
use it we got a few beta testers they
started telling other people and
literally within months we had thousands
of apps using crashlytics tons of people
begging us to use the product
and signing up and trying to get on the
waitlist and so on and opening it up and
so it really struck me the difference
between a pure need like a real visceral
need that people have in order to do
their business and something that is
sort of a nice to have and creo
unfortunately as a product wasn't a
complete replacement for email and so
you could just email the document and
get some comments back and that reduced
its need ultimately and so crashlytics
really struck us as like wow people are
desperate for this and that's what
resulted in the growth what's
interesting of course is among our big
apps using us was Twitter and Twitter
became obsessed with the product put it
out in both their iOS and Android apps
and we were going along they were happy
customer things were great and all of a
sudden in October of 2012 so about a
year after we had started you get a call
from them and they say hey uh have you
guys ever thought about working for
Twitter and we're like no hey why would
we do that oh and we have a great
business like the products going
gangbusters were really happy we have a
great team I don't see why we would go
work for Twitter that doesn't make sense
to me and they were like okay okay well
great chatting and hung up and that was
October in December they call back and
they're like hey we really want you two
guys to come think about working for
twitter at the very least come out and
meet with our exec team and we'll
actually fly you out there and so
because we were in boston at the time we
had started crossfit extent boston and
we're like okay fine but remembering
back to the lessons learned we had to do
this very very carefully because we had
no interest in selling crashlytics that
was not the goal we needed the team to
stay focused we are in pursuit of our be
round of funding which was going well we
had started charging for the product we
had a ton to build in order to scale up
the team in the business and so we
couldn't let this wind up being a huge
distraction that didn't pan out so we
came up with a plan this was December we
threw the team a holiday party on the
18th we gave them all these spiffy
jackets and on the 19th my co-founder
and I secretly flew to San Francisco and
we gave the team that week off and so no
one knew we were out here and the 20th
we met with Twitter and this is actually
for
Jack Dorsey's conference room ironically
he was not CEO at the time but he did
have a conference room and so we're
meeting with them there and asking them
point blank why do you want us to work
for Twitter we have this trajectory
we're building developer tools we don't
understand how that meets with a
consumer product why would these two and
like and by all means you can continue
to be a happy customer that would be
great and what really struck us was
Twitter's nuanced understanding of the
mobile space they and you gain this
perspective from being one of the
largest apps they had a very clear
vision of how they saw mobile developing
over the next five years and the
different products they would need to
build in order to be a permanent factor
in that ecosystem they also were very
very conscious and aggressive at
reinventing their developer platform and
so if I don't know how much you remember
Twitter history but Twitter was deeply
popular with developers in the early
days and there are tons of apps and tons
of things built on top of Twitter and
then in 2011 the company had made the
decision to sort of pull that back a
little bit and discourage people from
building clients and that had frustrated
in fairness a lot of developers and so
here in 2012 Twitter had recognized that
and wanted to go and sort of reinvent
their image for developers and Twitter
is an extremely it's an incredible
platform for developers to build on
today and they wanted to go and make
that a reality and so this got us more
intrigued and now we understood that
this wasn't simply they needed to own a
crash reporting tool because they used
it this was that they saw us as sort of
a beacon of this new wave of developer
tools that developers had fallen in love
with at a massive scale on mobile and
maybe we could build upon that to do
more things and so they asked to see our
road map so we showed him a rough road
map we had and this is the actual slide
and so we're doing crash reporting we
wanted to build a beta distribution tool
we wanted to go into analytics and then
way down in the future we wanted to do
some roi or monetization stuff so move
further up the stack from developers to
product marketers to app marketers and
sales and so on and that was the long
path of the company that we've been
pitching and as we started talking with
them what blew us away is that this was
almost exactly what they wanted to build
and so we made a few tweaks to the road
map but largely it was identical we
inserted a Twitter SDK Twitter didn't
have an SDK at the time and so we would
have to go build that
and that was great and fine but
otherwise the roadmap was basically the
same and that blew our minds we had such
complete strategic alignment that they
basically had painted for us our own
roadmap that we had been working on
internally and we were like wow this
becomes deeply compelling and we could
leverage then Twitter's brand and
notoriety and their willingness to build
all of this and offer all of this for
free instead of charging for the tools
as a way to very very quickly scale up
the platform and so if we look at it
through the same rubric there are
actually quite a bit of pros here they
have massive scale brand as i talked
about incredible culture phit twitter
actually employs seven Mayfield Fellows
today and a ton of Stanford students so
I also knew a bunch of people there
already that I could go do background
checks with and see how they liked it
and were eager to work with them again
so that was fantastic there was a very
clear product need right they had this
developer gap that they wanted to fill
and they didn't have an SDK so we could
fit right in clear strategic alignment
they've made a commitment to continue
investing in it they wanted to double
our team they wanted to make the product
free and yeah they wanted to make the
product free and so of course it's not
all rosy there are few cons and so what
are these well we were questioning sort
of their reputation amongst developers
it's been off and on and we ended up
ultimately seeing this as an opportunity
we thought that we could really help
Twitter reset its reputation with
developers and build a new platform for
the future for them and so maybe that
could shift over to the pros column
there was also of course opportunity
cost we were excited to go build our own
big business and learn a lot from that
and so really what it came down to is
were they willing to do this deal were
they willing to make a fair trade of
value that made it worth our while to go
work on this with Twitter instead of
pursuing it on our own and that's of
course when you get into negotiation and
so my co-founder led most of this and
went back and forth over countless phone
calls over the next four days in that
weekend and actually ultimately kept
them up negotiating until 2am Christmas
Eve remember this was late December and
we ended up deciding to go for it and
sign the turn sheet at 10am Christmas
morning and so that had been an
incredible period in one sense you're
like wow that's a
edible Christmas on the other hand it's
like okay wow we have way too much to do
now and we need to get back and tell
everyone because keep in mind nobody
knew we hadn't even told the team we
were in San Francisco and so I wanted to
talk to again a few things that we got
right and wrong so this I've harped on
we had complete strategic alignment I
think this is deeply essential to the
long-term success of the count of the
acquisition we had credible funding
alternatives so we were negotiating from
a very strong position we actually had
at least a year of runway already left
so we'd had no need to sell we were
already had the b round almost closed in
fact our investors agreed to match any
valuation twitter gave us and so we had
total optionality there and so that
worked very well we also because only my
co-founder and i knew had complete
control over all sides of the story and
this became deeply important and so the
two of us knew exactly who each other
talked to and what we said and what the
messaging was so we could control the
message not just just to Twitter and not
just to our team but to our investors to
our advisers to our legal team etc and
so this actually made the process far
less stressful than I think it would
have been and far less chaotic because
we were able to run it with such a small
core group of people the key there is
you have to live up to your team's trust
and so we had built a team of 18 people
14 engineers of the course the past year
and a half and it was essential they had
basically taken the job put their life
in our hands because they believed in
what we wanted to go do they wanted to
join a start-up and they didn't
necessarily want to go work for Twitter
that wasn't part of their plan and so it
was on us to motivate that to explain
why we ended up making this decision and
why we did it without their knowledge or
buy in and why we believe that this
would ultimately make all of us far more
successful than if we had pursued the
product individually and to hammer this
home we also of course had to take care
of the financial side and so a cool
thing here is actually most of our team
almost the entire team had been with us
less than a year and so the way standard
option agreements work as there's a
one-year cliff and then it vest over
four years and
if someone leaves in the first year you
could actually wipe the slate clean they
could get nothing they would none of
their equity would count and that would
have been terrible we now would sell the
company without their knowledge and then
not give them anything that's insane and
so we actually decided to do the
opposite and so my co-founder and I fast
forwarded their vesting all four years
and so even the people that actually
only been there a month got their entire
four years of equity and that converted
into equity and Twitter because that's
why they put our trust in us it put
their trust in us because they believed
that this was a company they wanted to
be a part of and a founding team that
they wanted to work for and so I think
this is an essential analog to doing
this with and balancing the transparency
there is of course we had to get
something wrong the thing I would call
out here is reporting structure as we
negotiated the deal we came to an
agreement with them to that we would
report directly to the vp of engineering
which seemed great at the time and that
was great very quickly Twitter actually
did a reorg and we wound up reporting
way deep in engineering for a period of
months and it wasn't the end of the
world we all we ultimately corrected
that and kept building but it really
struck me that we didn't get the support
we needed and we should have been more
thoughtful about this and the context
here is with box box was a 40-person
company at the time didn't really matter
where we reported twitter was much
larger and i didn't fully anticipate how
much reporting structure does matter in
larger organizations to determine what
level of support and visibility you have
and so I think we should have been a
little more clear about this but this is
really I think the only thing we got
wrong and this has been an incredibly
successful acquisition from my
perspective and from our team's
perspective we kept investing in
crashlytics we've modernized the product
we have scaled it immensely over the
past year crashlytics has been used by
over a million different apps across
over a billion mobile devices so it
really is actually pervasive we're on
most mobile devices that are active
today which is pretty crazy what I'm
most proud of is that in the two and a
half and up coming up to three years on
the acquisition not a single person on
our team has left and so we have our
entire original team we've actually
tripled the team we now have 75
engineers and we have been building
fabric
and so when you saw the roadmap this was
the ultimate goal we joined with the
mission to reinvent Twitter's developer
platform and effectively went heads down
for two years in order to do that and so
we expanded critics we built that beta
distribution thing we built an analytics
tool we built Twitter's SDK and we
launched that a year ago at Twitter
flight under the branding fabric and so
if you're into app development i would
check this out there's a whole bunch of
cool tools you can use and minor plug
we're on stage next week next Wednesday
for Twitter flight again and we have the
whole next generation of tools that
we're launching so super excited for
that so that's the story of Twitter and
crashlytics and so now I want to sort of
turn the tables and go to the other side
of the table and talk about what it's
like to be on Twitter's side because
I've had the distinct privilege over the
past three years to see a lot of deals
from Twitter side and help advise them
on different startups to acquire and how
to go through the process and so for my
direct experience this is the funnel
I've seen I should point out that
Twitter does on average one acquisition
a month so it's a massive operation
they've acquired a ton of companies I've
seen a sliver of that and so from my
perspective I've seen about 50 companies
evaluated contacted to see if they if
this is interesting we've pretty deeply
evaluated 12 of them over that time we
seriously considered six of them and
started negotiating with them and
ultimately three closed and so the key
takeaway here is it is actually
incredibly unlikely for a deal to happen
only one in roughly 17 of these deals
panned out and so there's so many
endless things that can go wrong along
the way I wanted to break this down a
little and talk about what we look like
from what we look for from Twitter's
side first it's important to understand
the different types of acquisitions and
the first one you've probably heard a
lot about is very popular in the valley
over the past couple years or aqua hires
and I put this at the bottom because
these are probably the simplest and in
terms of monetary value lowest deals
that companies do and the goal here is
simply talent and so this is a great
team of engineers that have gotten
together they've built a product for one
reason or another the product doesn't
pan out that's fine tons of companies
fail that's great you learn a lot from
it but ultimately they want to go and
join
larger company and still work together
as a team and aqua hires are actually
really interesting because you have a
team that works well together which is
which is harder than you would expect
because instead you're just sort of
hiring one person after another and it's
and you have to do a lot of work to
guarantee the culture fit to make sure
you're assembling a tight-knit team here
you can go and acquire tight-knit team
all in one package and so that's why
this has become more popular the next
sort of level I'd say of acquisitions
our technology deals and I would put the
in creo sale to box firmly in this camp
this is where the company had a clear
need they had recognized the need and
they needed to go and build a whole
bunch of technology in order to do that
and it's a cost-benefit analysis you
could either take that on and hire a
bunch of people and staff up a team and
maybe it would take a year to two years
to go build or you can try to identify a
smaller company that already owns that
technology and you want to bring it in
house and so we do a lot of these deals
as well the most rare and the largest
deals are these strategic ones and so
this is where you are augmenting your
business in a deeply strategic way in
order to go after a new market and so I
would put the crashlytics deal in this
bucket because Twitter didn't really
have a strong developer platform they
know they needed one they wanted to buy
not just technology that wouldn't have
particularly helped them they wanted to
buy an entire product and a market and a
brand within the developer community in
order to go pursue that space and so
we've done a whole bunch of these deals
periscope falls into this camp tell
apart falls into this camp mopub falls
into this camp and so these are sort of
the bigger name deals that you hear
about and read about and what's
interesting is how these happen and so
on the Aqua higher and technology side
it's typically the startup approaches
Twitter so we canvassed the space and
we're sort of aware of what's going on
but ultimately it's the startups
decision that it's time to go look for
suitors and they would approach big
companies and see if there's a match on
the strategic side is almost entirely
the opposite and it's us on the product
side of the large company thinking about
where we need to go and where we should
make an investment and that's when we
canvassed a space look at all the
potential players and then try to meet
with them and understand who would be
the best fit and so what does this
process actually look like starts of
course with a call as I talked about
when they called us goes on if that goes
well to a strategy
meeting with the founders we really want
to understand where they're coming from
what they want to build what kind of
team they build if that goes well we
move it on to a tech talk so we bring in
a bunch of the lead engineers and really
understand what they've built and how
they've built it it's fascinating
understanding all the different
architectures that companies are using
today and some we like better some would
match better with Twitter's
infrastructure and some wouldn't and so
it's always a great discussion to
understand the trade-offs they've made
if that goes well we move on to
interviews and in almost every case we
ideally want to interview the entire
team and again it's because cultural fit
is so important and then finally it when
it comes down to of course the
negotiation and so what we're looking
for here is we're really looking for a
lineman and culture this is not just a
thing to care about from the startup
side this is a thing that the big
companies and Twitter particularly cares
deeply about and we spend most of our
time making sure that we're only
bringing in people who we think will be
successful within Twitter and within the
culture that we have we of course want
strong technology there are tons of
different ways to solve problems and
we're looking for a really elegant
really powerful really scalable approach
to solving problems we're looking for a
great team I'd say this is actually
where most of the deals fall through is
it turns out as we interview everyone of
course there's going to be amazing
people and weaker people and it comes
down to the percentages and so
ultimately we have to make a really
tough call that if there's too few great
people on a team we can't justify
bringing the entire team into the
company and so as you go and start your
companies and build your team's really
focus on assembling the best group of
people you can to put yourselves in the
position of success here and then of
course finally we're looking for fair
value and we want to really understand
what would this have taken us to build
or us to win this market or whatever it
might be cool and so a few last things
to remember almost all deals fail and so
as you go through processes like these
don't get frustrated this is sort of the
name of the game expect it will fail
actually and just worked in a
disciplined manner to talk and lay
everything out on the table and be
transparent and that's probably the
easiest way to very quickly judge
whether it's looking like a success or
failure both you and the acquire must be
in a hundred percent
they must be committed and what I mean
by that is let's say you've been working
on a company for quite a while you're a
little bit tired you're feeling burned
out an acquisition is not the path to
your vacation it is the opposite and so
you need to be far more energized than
you ever have been and if you feel like
you can't give this new chapter of your
company the energy it deserves it is not
going to end well and you have to deeply
deeply understand that the same is for
the acquirer and so it's really
important to understand because they're
a larger company they have strategic
initiatives where do you fit in to their
strategic priorities and their market
needs and do you see that need
continuing long-term or is this a hobby
thing that they're experimenting with
but probably won't invest in try to
learn meet as many people and learn as
much about that as you possibly can and
as I mentioned this is just the start of
the journey this is going to be four
years of your life and so you cannot see
this as an exit and so carefully
consider a strategic alignment culture
fit their ability to invest going
forward in your team and your product
and ultimately the reporting structure
if it's a larger company you're talking
to so I wanted to end just before we go
into questions with two higher level
things the first is a deep thank you to
Kimber my co-founder and in cryo Wayne
my co-founder crashlytics and Jessica it
is a hundred percent the truth the in
cryo would have failed without Kimber it
was incredible working with her and she
led most the negotiation with box and so
huge thanks to her for everything she
did for the company and for making that
happen same goes with Wayne he's the one
of the most brilliant negotiators I've
ever met you might be catching a theme I
am horrific at negotiating I love
building products and writing code and
trying to make stuff I don't like the
business side of things and so Wayne was
absolutely essential in that and then
just taught me everything I know about
acquiring companies from the Twitter
side and she was Mayfield with me and
we've known each other for a long time
but the opportunity to work with her and
see how twitter has gone about and very
professionally and very diligently
acquired so many companies over such a
short period of time was fascinating and
so huge thanks to them and finally I
want to
tell everyone here to stay true to your
mission it would be terrible if your
takeaway from this talk was okay I'm
going to go build something and I'm
going to get acquired that is not the
goal whatsoever and when you go out and
raise funding inevitably you're going to
be asked so why are you building this
company are you going are you building
it to be acquired or are you building it
to IPO and I hate that question because
what's happening is the investors
assigning a definition of success
totally independent of why I started the
company I didn't start the company to
sell it I didn't start the company to
IPO I didn't start the company to exit
it I started the company to solve a
problem like i started the company to
stop mobile apps from crashing because
that's really annoying and so you have
to stay true to your mission the
crashlytics did not when was not
successful today twitter bought us it
was not successful today twitter IPO d
it wasn't successful when we launched
fabric last year it's still not
successful today because mobile apps are
crashing over a billion times a day and
so when you're thinking about
opportunities for your team and your
company focus on the ones that will help
you achieve your message your mission
instead of seeing it as an exit thank
you
you have the first time you ask first of
all right Tina so you go from being the
boss from being you know the founder and
calling all the shots to now working for
someone else can you talk a little bit
about that yeah it is a fascinating
transition because yeah that's exactly
right you go from leading this team from
making all the decisions owning all the
decisions to all of a sudden having to
work within this structure and I think
that's why the the strategic alignment
is so important and you have to be very
clear in setting expectations and so we
were very clear with Twitter that like
okay if you believe developers are a
priority then we are going to go and
build you a developer platform and you
have to give us the leeway to go do that
and so it is tough because founders are
used to this autonomy and in many
companies they aren't used two groups of
the company wanting or having a tonna me
separate from the rest and so this is a
skill that the acquirers learn and weave
for example been deeply intentional
about letting periscope keep their
office keep the roadmap keep their plans
sort of run their app in their business
as they would because that's ultimately
what will make that team successful and
it's not our mission to go and merge you
in and like trample everything you've
done and all your your customs and
everything ultimately we're doing the
deal because we want the startup to be
successful more successful than they
would have been independently and so you
have to strike the right balance the
other thing I'd say is I think this is
often the case why founders tend to
start initiatives within companies and
so even if they're joining a company and
maybe their product has wound down or
whatever it is instead of joining a team
doing something in many cases I've seen
founders tend to want to start a new
project or new whole area of the product
or whatever for the company because they
feel that degree of freedom and there
there are certainly cases where it
doesn't work out yeah oh okay first of
all thanks so much for coming this is a
really great opportunity to learn a lot
about this huh so my question I was just
curious once you sign the deal with
Twitter and then you went back to Austin
how did you break the news to your team
and how do they respond initially was
there like presentation were some kind
of that much yeah great questions oh
sorry so the question was after we
signed the deal with Twitter how did we
go back to Boston the team and how did
we break
the news to them and we were stressing
out about this endlessly because you
sort of have one opportunity to message
this correctly and so what we decided to
do and remember this was Christmas and
we've given everyone the week off and so
everyone was supposed to come back the
Friday before New Year's and we were
going to do a 2012 year in review for
the company and that had been previously
scheduled and then we were obviously
people would go and take more time off
for New Year's and so on and so we
decided hey we can't change anything we
can't like schedule some random thing
and that will freak everyone out and so
we're going to do a 2012 year in review
and so my co-founder and I spent hours
making a slide deck a photo deck where I
got those photos of the year and what we
done and it talked about all our
milestones and the new people joining
the team and our office space and
everything you would possibly add to a
slide deck about your year as a start-up
and it ended with the holiday party
except it didn't and there was the next
slide and so we pitched it as basically
well you thought this was the end but
there's not there's more news and so we
told this whole story of flying out to
Twitter and presenting in the conference
room and negotiating with them and so on
and there's actually a photo that I
chose not to show of Wayne and I having
dinner celebrating with champagne
afterwards except that it was overly
romantic and like under a Christmas
wreath because it was Christmas time and
so that got everyone laughing and we
talked through the Delta in the roadmaps
and that was very compelling and so how
somewhat like no one had their dreams
shattered we were building exactly the
same thing just under a larger mandate
and we could make the product free and
so that I think played well with the
team and then to bring in sort of
reinforcement we timed when our lead
investor would show up with some
champagne for everyone and some more
words of congratulations and advice so
the goal was to message it sort of
slowly and break the news and then
celebrate it's gone the rest of the day
partying Tom sub companies require the
team to relocate and so what have been
shown to Twitter that's a great question
so the question was in many acquisitions
they require the team to relocate and so
how did that pan out or play out here
that is very true and Twitter asked us
to relocate and this is one of the
things I
in touch on but you should cover in the
negotiations and we were very clear with
them that the team was not relocating
that people moved to Boston and live in
Boston for very specific reasons and if
they were willing to move to Silicon
Valley they likely would have moved to
Silicon Valley and so we in fact did
offer the entire team all 18 people the
opportunity to move only to ever took us
up on it and they took us up on at about
a year and a half after the fact and so
we ended up actually starting Twitter's
Boston office and so Twitter built out
an office space there it's actually
there now largest remote engineering
office of they've since acquired a bunch
of other companies in Boston and so we
have about 140 people out there no
coincidence you that the team as a part
of the D is a part of the process how
would you intend to great question yes
so the question was interviews are part
of the process how do you do interviews
without disclosing this to the team
brilliant insight and so the way this
works is it depends on the dynamics of
the deal and so it and it depends who
has the stronger negotiating position
and what the founders want because
frankly a lot of founders actually don't
take this approach and just bring the
whole team in which puzzles me but they
do and so if the founders are very set
that they do not want the team to find
out and a lot of founders are it depends
on the dynamics and so if if the
founders have a strong case for and
we're very bullish on the deal and we
want to make it happen then that's fine
and we'll actually go ahead and sign a
term sheet that's basically condition
alized on a certain percentage of the
interviews going correctly and so you
sign the term street and then of course
they tell the team and then everyone
comes in and talks and in the case where
maybe it's an aquil here there's like
they have a less negotiating position
it's a condition so it's like sorry like
if you want us to engage deeper in this
deal you have to tell them and bring
them in yes hi step will be spent most
of the time is that are we getting the
right price so how do you ensure that
you are getting the right price
yeah that's actually this step we spend
the least amount of time on probably all
things considered the price within some
range really doesn't matter and so we
spend by far oh sorry what the question
was how much time you spend on
negotiating the price and how do you
make sure you get a fair value and yeah
we really don't spend a lot of energy
there we spend most of the energy on the
culture fit because the the thinking is
it'll be either successful if it's not
and if it's successful the price is
probably a rounding error like with any
luck it's a rounding error and so we try
to offer make a very fair offer we look
at comparables we look at your latest
rounds of funding and where they valued
the company and there's there's a little
negotiating room but not a lot yeah you
said that one of the lessons learned
from the first acquisition was that you
waited too long at the same time with
the Twitter acquisition you said you've
got a call but then you kind of ignored
it and then two months later you took it
seriously I didn't you feel like you
could have acted earlier on the second
acquisition coming from the first one in
the nest and learn a great question so
yeah so the question was the first
acquisition waited too long to happen
this one we sort of took a call and
ignored it and and then waited and so
why did we wait too long again and it's
totally different dynamics we had zero
interest in selling crashlytics and so
from our perspective it was way too
early I mean you could say it was too
early even when we did do the deal so
for today I don't think so I think it
was a hundred percent the right decision
and the right timing to do it but yeah I
guess it was just a different mindset
the way we looked at it is we believed
the Twitter would very very rapidly
because of their brand legitimize us and
we would become sort of the de facto
crash reporting solution which I argued
has more or less happened and that then
how long would it take for us
independently to achieve that same
trajectory and we as co-founders sort of
debated this and thought that hey
Twitter's value add was about three
years worth of execution and at that
point it became straight forward to do
the deal Robbie you started yet
incredible you while you're a senior at
Stanford what advice would you give the
other
undergrads they've been thinking about
starting companies while in school great
question so the question was i started
in cryo as a senior which is true what
advice would I give to current
undergrads it's really important to say
that we had no intention of starting a
company that was not the goal the goal
was to start working on a project that
was fun and to start training ourselves
to evaluate business ideas and making
decisions as if we were a business so we
built this idea sharing tool we then
recognized that and then we did a ton of
research and market research and talking
to people and customer development and
realized that idea sharing wasn't a
great space and so we quote pivoted even
though pivot was no word then over to
document feedback and we were just sort
of following this path like just doing
side projects as students and it was
really only when we came and talked with
you and for advice that we realized that
maybe this was interesting and maybe
this was a path we should pursue further
and so I'd say don't like my personal
opinion is don't drop out i think you
should continue your time here you learn
so much here and it's so valuable to be
here and you can never really get that
back like I certainly miss being on
campus but spend as much time as you can
doing side projects and teaching
yourself working with people meeting
with people in the industry take
advantage of the fact that you can say
you're a student and anyone will meet
with you which is crazy and the moment
that's not the case then you can't do
that and to take advantage of that the
other thing I'd say just more tactically
is take a vacation after graduation we
started in cryo full time before
graduation about a week before and I've
haven't taken a vacation since so that
that's been rough yeah back to when you
were a student here I mean obviously you
really squeeze the juice out of your
your experience especially related to
entrepreneurship are there things you
wish you had done when you're a student
that you did besides taking a vacation
after graduation things that you had
would make yourself in the things you
would have learned sort of things you
would have classes would have taken yeah
great question um there's really only
one big one and that's go abroad I never
thought I had time to go abroad and so
never traveled anywhere and I would have
loved to do that and retro
I'd say one other thing which I did do
but I think looking back was more
valuable than I understood it to be at
the time and that is try to do something
that is aggressively outside of your
skill set so I was a CS major I love
coding I still love coding I spent
literally every hour that I wasn't in
class coding and I decided my sophomore
year to get a marketing job and be a
campus rep and it happened to be Apple
which was a smooth transition into
marketing but that was actually
incredible in retrospect and I didn't
appreciate it at the time because it
forced me to talk with people and meet
people and be able to explain products
and think about it from the users point
of view instead of the code point of
view and so my advice would be like do
something totally outside your comfort
zone while you're a student because you
can and no one cares and it's a great
learning opportunity and that will help
you sort of see a broad perspective as
you go forward I'm sure you will agree
that this was totally fabulous please
join thank you
you